there's been a very small but very
significant change in the outlook for
the 2022 midterms over the last 48 hours
and that change is that for the first
time in these midterms by a very very
very small margin
the 538 senate forecast has democrats
projected to hold control of the united
states senate and this would be huge
historically and it would be huge
practically because of everything that's
on the table looking at 2022 and 2024 so
we're going to go through it piece by
piece newsweek noticing this with an
article democrats favor to win senate
for first time as polling improves per
538 and indeed when we look at the 538
update
uh we now see that they correctly call
it a toss-up in the sense that the
margin is so small that you can't say it
is a big advantage for democrats but the
most likely scenario
uh of 100 outcomes is that democrats win
52 seats out of 100 which would actually
give democrats a bigger
um advantage in the senate than they
currently have remember currently it is
a 50-50 senate with kamal harris as the
tie-breaking vote as the vice president
who is the president of the senate in
cases of 50-50 doesn't do much for
democrats when you need 60 votes as you
do for many legislative activities but
it does make a significant um uh
it is an advantage it is a majority when
you have 50 50 situations now as we know
for 50 50 situations you need every
democrat on board including joe manchin
and kirsten cinema that is a story for a
different day which we have covered
extensively so what is what are the
repercussions what is the impact of this
uh let's first talk about historical
context number one
when a party wins the white house
taking it from the other party
in a presidential election
they almost always lose in the first
midterms so looking at a historical
precedent joe biden democrats took the
white house from trump and republicans
in 2020
democrats should lose and do poorly in
the november 22 midterms i think when we
spoke to political scientist rachel
bittikoffer on the show
she said that there's only like three
examples in history of where it went a
different way so if indeed democrats are
able to
retain control
expand the majority in the senate
um not lose power
that would already be historically
anomalous or anomalous
and it would um signify that something
different is taking place now what might
that something be there's two analyses
that are possible
one would be
if democrats don't do terribly in
november it will be because of the
temporary trumpist constituency that
only cared about trump and now they've
bailed
and things have gone sort of back to
quote normal that would be one possible
analysis the other possible analysis
would be uh that is not the explanation
the explanation would be democrats would
have lost
were it not for
roe v wade being overturned very
unpopular with americans
and nothing being done on gun safety
despite prominent mass shooting after
prominent mass shooting two issues
abortion and guns that are not typically
good issues for democrats in elections
this time around polling suggests might
actually be good issues now all of this
is hypothetical all of this is
if democrats manage to retain control
in one or both houses
and as you can see the margin is very
very very small so
this call it a 52 chance you know you we
can interpret these numbers in a lot of
different ways and some of them are not
strictly speaking statistically accurate
but call it a 52 chance when i see 52
percent
i believe it is correct to call it a
toss-up and remember that hillary
clinton based on these models had an 85
chance of winning in 2016
the results fell in the other 15 now it
doesn't mean that the estimates were
wrong something that's 85 percent likely
to happen might not happen but the point
is when we say 52
it's basically a coin flip and it's
going to come down to
who votes who votes everyone must vote
everyone must vote and we're going to be
highlighting the key races on which
control of the senate could hinge there
are disagreements among some about
in particular right now is it more
important for democrats to keep control
of the house or keep control of the
senate on the senate the argument would
be more legislative in the house the
argument would be more about preventing
all of these bogus investigations into
joe biden into anthony fauci maybe even
into hunter biden why the house would
investigate hunter biden who has nothing
to do with the administration i still
couldn't tell you but there are
differing opinions about which
uh side of congress would be more
important to control i believe it is
both and uh no no race should be
conceded
no race should be ignored but we should
also be strategic particularly in the
senate because it's likely to hinge on
just a handful of races so if you want
to say this is good news you absolutely
can democrats should be losing
if you want to say it's bad news
you could also make that case and the
bad news would be
despite all of the abandonment of the
republican party of any substantive
policy despite the fact that they're not
even pretending to try to think about
being productive members of a
legislative body
they still might take control of the
senate and so you can find the good or
the bad in this as with most most cases
there's a little bit of both
but the opportunity is here
for
an unusual
event historically which is democrats
win the white house and they don't lose
control of everything in the next
midterms
one of the things that is a troubling
sign for joe biden is that even some
democrats now elected democrats are
backing away from saying absolutely i
would support joe biden's re-election in
2024 we're going to look at a clip of
tim ryan who uh i support in his race in
ohio for the senate it's a very
important race actually um he's running
against jp right
j.d mandel no he's running against jd
vance
and um
tim ryan's been on the show i think he's
i think he's great i hope that he wins
in ohio but
he is correctly reading the mood on the
ground in ohio
which is that even democrats don't
really want joe biden to run for
reelection now where do i get that well
i get it from polling
there is a majority of democrats at this
point that want someone other than joe
biden to be the nominee in 2024.
tim ryan appeared on fox news and he was
asked would you support joe biden's
re-election in 2024 and he basically
punts and i think that there is a lot to
read into the punting but let's take a
look at the clip first
uh so we'll keep watching all that final
question to you there was the first
presidential primary state new hampshire
poll that came out yesterday and it
showed support for this president
president joe biden for his re-election
it is plummeting in fact it suggested
that biden and buddha judge are now tied
in a hypothetical 2024 presidential
primary match-up do you support the
president in his re-election bid
i'm working now for by the way the
question's a little bit silly because
joe biden hasn't actually filed for
re-election so so the question's a
little bit wonky uh they're not not won
the question's a little bit squishy
uh but let's listen to the answer on my
own election and that's all i'm focused
on and sorry i talked over the key
moment so let's back it up and take it
from the top president in his
re-election bid
i'm working on my own election and
that's all i'm focused on right now
we've got a little under four months
here in ohio and we're running a great
campaign we're up in the polls and
working really hard so i'm just gonna
focus on that and then we can chat about
that uh after i win and get in the
united states senate i'll be happy to
comment well i think it was it was noted
that that the president held a an event
there in your state recently a speech on
the economy i believe if my memory
serves me and you didn't show that was
certainly a message you were sending
right well it was an event where we
saved a hundred thousand pensions in
ohio through the rescue package which
was significant many of those teamsters
working-class people it was a great
thing but i had commitments in southern
ohio and i'm not going to back out on
normal ohioans average ohioans to like a
schedule that i had and then leave them
to go see the president like i'm not
doing that stuff these are great people
and i'm gonna i'm gonna keep my meetings
but we gotta get focused on the economy
all right so so i mean listen he's doing
some dancing and rightly so i had a
commitment and the economy is the focus
and all these things this is not a hard
thing to dance around
if you want to send a different message
right tim ryan could say you know it's
too early to talk about 2024
but i know that democrats will select a
great nominee and i will support that
nominee right okay so you he could have
said something like that he didn't say
that and there are two interpretations
one
tim ryan doesn't really like joe biden
for president i actually don't think
that's the case i think tim ryan likes
joe biden absolutely fine
tim ryan is trying to win
a senate seat
in a sometimes red state of
ohio which would be hugely impactful for
democrats in the senate when there is a
huge fight for who's going to control
the senate next time tim ryan accurately
believes that ohio democrats and
independents and maybe some republicans
who could vote for him in november might
be soured on biden why do i say tim ryan
accurately believes that because that's
what the polling shows and i know people
get mad at me but joe biden has a low
approval rating it's historically low
it's the lowest at this point in his
presidency
compared to any president going all the
way back to truman in the second year of
his presidency in the middle of the
1940s so it is correct as an assessment
that biden's not popular and my guess
would be that tim ryan being
an ohio congressman and wanting to be an
ohio senator is aware that in ohio in
particular the numbers might be even
worse for biden than they are nationally
but the point here is
this can become a self-fulfilling
feedback loop
um the public becomes disillusioned with
biden which is happening it's it's what
the approval rating shows uh and then
this causes democratic elected officials
to back away from biden
which furthers the
implausibility of a successful
re-election campaign
which further reduces the number of
people that want biden to run again it
can become this feedback loop and it
sort of seems to be happening if the
best strategy remember
in two home let me think now in 2008
when it was mccain versus obama obama
george w bush was basically missing from
the campaign trail
george w bush was a drag down based on
his approval for republicans wanting to
get elected john mccain included
is it possible that biden is going to
end up being the same
and the question will be answered in the
next few months does joe biden start
showing up at rallies in support of 2022
democratic candidates let me know what
you think find me on twitter
at dpakman make sure you're following me
there
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
i would love it if you signed up for the
david pakman show membership program
which you can do at
joinpackman.com we do depend on the
support of our audience people listening
to the podcast listening on the radio
watching on tv watching clips on youtube
and the primary source of that support
is the membership program all of these
other platforms where one can support
independent creators they take these
slices of every payment some take five
percent some take 20 20 30 40 even
percent uh when you sign up at
joinpakman.com
two percent of your payment goes to
processing the credit and debit cards
and we keep the rest meaning the money
really comes to the show and stays
within the show
it also comes with great perks strong
perks including the daily bonus show as
well as commercial free audio and video
streams of the show
sign up at
joinpacman.com the republican national
committee is sending a warning to failed
former president donald trump
if you announce your candidacy for
president when we're trying to win our
midterm elections we will stop paying
your legal bills which of course raises
the question why are they paying trump's
legal bills which is a question we will
get to in a moment abc news reports rnc
warning to trump if you run for
president we stop paying your legal
bills let's take a look at this clip
from abc's good morning america with
george stephanopoulos explaining what is
going on republican leaders are
threatening to stop paying the former
president's legal bills if he announces
a 2024 run for president chief
washington correspondent john carl has
the story in john we're talking about
millions of dollars george this is an
entirely unprecedented arrangement the
republican national committee is paying
and has been paying donald trump's
personal legal bills some of these
related to his businesses in new york
1.7 million dollars more than that just
since october most recent payment we
know of more than 50 000
last month so now they're making this
threat and republicans really don't want
donald trump announcing that he's
running for president as they head into
the midterms where they think they're
gonna do well yeah this is really
something a threat from the rnc quietly
said uh we found out about it uh that
they will stop paying his legal bills
when he or if he announces he's running
for president the big backdrop here is
they don't want him to run announce he's
running before the midterms they want to
run mid-term campaigns based on joe
biden and the economy if donald trump
announces he's running this fall it
messes with that strategy so they're
saying you do that we'll stop paying
your bills so that's the concept the
republican national committee has made
the calculation if trump announces soon
which the reports are trump is
increasingly thinking of doing because
he thinks it'll help him with his legal
trouble and criminal probes against him
if trump announces before the midterms
we will stop paying trump's legal bills
now are they making the right
calculation is it true
that trump announcing will sort of turn
the midterms into a referendum on trump
and potentially hurt republican
candidates i actually don't know the
answer to that and it would be something
we would need to study separately but
one big question is why is the
republican national committee paying
donald trump's legal bills and the best
answer i've been able to find is that
keeping trump out of jail looks better
for them that donald trump's legal
problems
are growing conspicuously uh more than
they already have and they are already
pretty significant
would make republicans and the
republican party look bad and it might
help candid or hurt candidates rather in
november of 2022. it is sort of strange
how a multi-billionaire needs someone
else to pay his legal fees but donald
trump is known for hiring lawyers and
then not paying them now one of the real
questions that has come up as a result
of this and we're going to talk about it
tomorrow
is
trump's not a candidate right now
trump's not paying his own legal bills
what is happening with all those
millions of dollars that people are
donating to donald trump remember donate
to stop the steal
donate to us because we're gonna do this
that and the other thing and elections
and all this stuff
what exactly is being done with that
money and hilariously karl rove the
longtime republican strategist wrote a
hilarious it's hilarious in spite of
itself he's not trying to be funny but
it is hilarious
karl rove wrote an op-ed in the wall
street journal saying
where is the money going that is being
donated to donald trump and it's a
fantastic question and we're going to be
talking about that tomorrow so a threat
from the rnc to trump
i honestly
whatever is worse for the rnc and for
republicans i hope trump does it and let
trump and the republican national
committee destroy each other if trump
announcing early that he is running for
president is considered bad and will
anger the rnc all the better i hope he
does it for that reason alone we have to
talk about what is going on in the state
of georgia
and i know that there are people who
aren't going to like this conversation
republicans in georgia are going to vote
for a man
who can barely speak and is unable to
explain a single policy
this is a man who can barely put
together a coherent sentence
and unfortunately because of some of the
circumstances
it's almost like the elephant in the
room that cannot be discussed now i'm
talking about former professional
football player
herschel walker
herschel walker is running for senate in
georgia against the incumbent democratic
senator rafael warnock
and walker
doesn't make any sense when he speaks he
seems unable to speak and unable to
think
and when you talk about it republicans
act all offended and they play the games
where they claim it's actually what the
left does they say that's racist
or you're stigmatizing mental illness
or you're being racist against ebonics
or whatever
now we're going to go through these
claims one by one and we have a new
example of herschel walker just making
no sense now i'm going to admit to you
i don't know
why walker can't speak
he played football there's speculation
that there is a brain injury that might
be at play but when you bring up the
brain injury part there are people who
say david it's not a brain injury it's
mental illness herschel walker has
talked about dissociative identity
disorder and then they will say if you
talk about a brain injury from football
you're ignoring the plight of mental
illness but at the same time mental
illness doesn't actually explain being
unable to speak or explain one policy
position ever
and then some people will show up and
say david that's racism you are
essentially just criticizing herschel
walker for speaking ebonics that's
racist but that's not it at all that's
not what's going on and ebonics doesn't
prevent you from answering a question it
it
it's it's crazy
that the right who says oh all the
leftists they get all offended
now they're playing the i'm offended
game when we go hey guys herschel walker
can't explain a single thing that he
believes the issue here really is
republican voters
seem willing to vote for someone to
avoid voting for a democrat who cannot
explain his opinion on any issue now
here's the latest example herschel
walker did one of these events in some
kind of bar or restaurant who knows
on fox news brian kilmeade uh
interviewed him and said hey
why aren't you going to debate or why
aren't you debating your opponent rafael
warnock and herschel walker just he
can't explain it it doesn't make any
sense
uh
senator raphael warnock wants to debate
you you didn't debate during the
primaries where you walked away with 68
of the republican votes
why would you commit to a debate well
first of all senator warnock has nothing
else to talk about he don't want to talk
about the high gas prices he don't want
to talk about the high groceries i've
told him many times i'm ready to debate
him anytime any day i just want to make
it for the fans not about a political
party or about some media and all
they're doing is talking i want to make
it a fair and equitable debate
are you worried about the moderator what
understand he's saying
he warnock doesn't have anything to talk
about
and i'm willing to debate if it's for
the fans
that that's not an answer
that that should immediately make us say
can he think because he's not saying
anything that makes sense
and there's other examples that we've
covered as well this one was when cnn
reporter manu raju
asked
hershel walker should there be new gun
laws after the texas shooting and he
says what i like to do is see it and
everything and stuff
with cnn
are you do you support any new gun laws
in the wake of this texas [ __ ]
he likes to see it and everything and
stuff and then the last example of this
uh he appeared like the following day or
the day after that on fox news and he
was asked about his solution to school
shootings and it was a department that
can look at young men looking at women
looking at social media see that is the
person willing that weapon you know cain
kia able you know and uh you know that's
the problem that we have and i said what
we need to do is look into how we can
stop those things you know he talked
about doing a disinformation what about
getting a department that can look at
young men that's looking at uh women
that looking at uh just social media
what about doing that looking into
things like that and we can stop that
that way but okay
this doesn't make any sense and the
really you know we're being hard on
herschel walker because he doesn't make
any sense but the republicans in georgia
are so
determined and desperate that rafael
warnock is bad
that they don't even mention that walker
doesn't actually say anything he seems
unable to actually put together a
coherent opinion about any particular
issue when it's joe biden
it's biden dementia
and biden stuttered
and so on and so forth and then herschel
walker has not been able to explain a
single policy position the entire
campaign
refused to debate in the primary so far
is refusing to debate in the general
election
and they don't say a word about it it is
number one obviously an incredible
double standard but number two
it says a lot about the modern
republican party
in georgia right now
that it doesn't even seem to phase them
like if i said to you
what is walker's plan to lower the gas
prices that he has identified as a
problem it's not that you might not know
it's that he has not explained it once
in any way that makes any sense
if i ask you well what is herschel
walker's plan on inflation or to create
jobs
you can look at the things that he has
said words have come out of his mouth i
mean there are letters which assemble
words that i generally speaking
recognize there is not an actual
position on anything and republicans if
you if you try to bring it up they go oh
you're either making fun of brain
injuries or mental illness or you're
you're racist this is exactly what they
accuse the left of doing
and now they themselves are doing it
it's wild out there folks it is wild we
will have these clips on our instagram
you can find us at david davidpakmanshow
on instagram you can find me on
instagram at
david.pakman we will take a quick break
and be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show so there's some pretty funny
coveted hijinks going on this is not the
most serious thing but it just shows how
petty everybody is and to some degree i
kind of like it and at least as far as
joe biden's concerned as many of you
know joe biden recently had covet and
there were some on the right we covered
allison steinberg and some others who
seemed sort of happy that joe biden had
covid they weren't straight up saying i
hope he dies and doesn't recover but
they certainly seem to be implying it
and yesterday president joe biden
returned to work officially
announced that he has tested negative
for covid his isolation can now end and
that it was mild all along
hello everyone
i've uh
just tested negative
for cover 19 after isolating for five
days
[Applause]
so those hoping for the demise of joe
biden due to covet unfortunately will be
disappointed but here's where it gets
petty and kind of funny
joe biden brought up this is just so
funny it's apropos of nothing biden
contrasted
his covet case where
it was mild
he didn't need oxygen he didn't get
helicoptered to walter reed for fears
that he would soon be unable to walk
under his own power you might remember
we later learned that when trump got
covered suddenly there was this
announcement oh he's being helicoptered
to walter reed what's going on
and we later learned that doctors and
advisors came to him and with tears in
their eyes they said sir you might want
to go to walter reed now because the way
this is going uh we may have to take you
there in a stretcher at some point and
trump didn't want the optics of that so
he flew to walter reed and biden just
kind of made fun of of trump for lack of
a better term that's really what he did
here here's the bottom line
when my predecessor got covered he had
to get helicoptered to walter reed
medical center he was severely ill
thankfully he recovered
when i got coveted i worked from
upstairs to the white house and the
office is upstairs and uh for the five
day period the difference is
vaccinations of course
but also three new tools free to all and
widely available
you don't need to be president to get
these tools to be used for your defense
right here's the bottom line the point
here is really to talk about vaccines
right the argument that joe biden is
making is
trump wasn't vaccinated and he had a
really serious case
i am vaccinated and i had a very mild
case now
these are not
really great arguments there's a bunch
of different things number one
biden physically seems healthier than
trump i mean let's be honest we know
trump's not really six three two thirty
nine uh trump is is obese
uh eats very unhealthy diet generally
okay so that predisposes trump to have a
more serious case than biden first and
foremost secondly these are different
variants and i am not making i don't
have the latest numbers as to whether
ba5 the current variant uh in terms of
hospitalization risk or whatever you
know and then you have to account for
the fact that yes it there could be a
different hospitalization risk but
when vaccinated what is the net
likelihood of being hospitalized now
versus back when trump had there's all
of this different stuff what's funny
about it
is biden just wants to make the point
that thanks to vaccines he had a mild
case compared to trump's serious case
but the funny thing is that it comes off
as again trump just wants to be the
alpha and the best and the strongest at
absolutely everything
and it seems like biden is kind of
ribbing him and you know that it
triggers trump very very badly now the
the the third layer that's really funny
is
sean hannity then pops up out of nowhere
to then run cover for trump about okay
trump went to walter reed but that was a
much stronger strain and again this is
all bs it's all a penis size contest but
everybody's playing their role and
hannity pops up as the trump defender
iden had to evoke the uniter that he is
his favorite subject donald trump take a
look
here's the bottom line
when my predecessor got covered he had
to get helicoptered to walter reed
medical center he was severely ill
thankfully he recovered
when i got coveted i worked from
upstairs to the white house and the
office is upstairs and uh for the that
five day period the difference is
vaccinations of course
now what joe failed to mention is the
current variant which is ba 5 the
dominant variant of omicron is much much
weaker than the original strain that
infected than president trump right
don't think for a second that biden is
any better
stronger
smarter
faster
nicer more intelligent whatever than
trump trump got hit with a hard variant
per virologist sean hannity whereas
biden got a weak variant and was
vaccinated i guess to some degree
hannity is kind of saying that the
vaccines work so anyway it's just all a
pissing match it really is but something
about it i found actually pretty funny
joe biden is back we're all glad to see
that a 15 year old
shot
three
of his four siblings
and then himself
and everybody is dead
and this is one of those cases i've said
before you gotta charge the people that
are supposed to be in charge of the gun
this is a tragedy but you've got to
charge the people that are supposed to
be in charge of the gun
alaska news source reports
four children dead in fairbanks after 15
year olds shot three siblings and
himself per troopers
four children are dead
god what a tragedy
after a 15 year old turned a gun on
three of his siblings and then took his
own life that's per alaska state
troopers
this happened on tuesday
troopers got a report of a shooting at a
subdivision north of fairbanks alaska
the troopers showed up and found four
kids dead from an apparent gunshot wound
troopers said that a 15 year old boy
shot three siblings the siblings are
were aged 5 8 and 17
and then shot himself oh it's three
other siblings in the home were not
injured not one other three other
siblings in the home
so
uh the parents of the children and one
other sibling were also not sorry one
sibling
three others is four and then the three
that were shot is seven and then eight
so you've got
a house it's an it's a very very small
house there's images of the house
uh in some of the news articles
you've got eight siblings
and you've got an unsecured gun
now there has not been a lot of detail
here but one of the questions is whose
gun was it and how did the 15 year old
get access to it well according to nbc
news
the gun was a family gun by the way the
term family gun that is uniquely
american it was a family gun but beyond
that it's all still part of an ongoing
investigation
um
if indeed
i mean listen family gun
the 15 year old is not allowed to have
the gun
so by family gun it probably means that
this was a firearm uh
that belonged to and was uh purchased by
the parent or parents
and if that's the case
the firearm being accessible to the 15
year old
would be
a negligent act by the parents by the
gun owners
and we often talk about when there are
these so-called accidental shootings
which are really negligent shootings
where the gun owner accidentally fires a
gun at someone we say well that's really
a tragedy and do we want to add
more to what is already a tragedy when a
dad accidentally shoots his own kid as
we've covered before
and the kid dies
that's the tragedy so do we really want
to go after the parent for a negligent
gun discharge
given that they've lost their kid well i
don't know it's not really my decision
to make
but further here we have a situation
where of of course this is a tragedy for
the parents
but what is the signal being sent
if the parents didn't properly store
and lock the firearm
and then it was accessible to a 15 year
old
who then killed three of his siblings
and himself
what's the message that that's sent if
the parents aren't charged
i don't know uh
i'd like to hear from you about that
one other aspect in general and when you
have an individual incident here this is
an individual mass shooting
um individual mass shootings and broader
statistics sometimes they correlate
sometimes they don't or whatever the
case may be
alaska has the number one gun homicide
rate in the country
the gun homicide rate in alaska is over
24 gun homicides
per hundred thousand people now if
you're wondering whether 24 is high
new york and massachusetts the two
states with the lowest gun homicide rate
have a gun homicide rate of three
okay consider that's we're talking about
seven times higher more than seven times
higher
uh the gun homicide rate is three
in new york and massachusetts and it's
more than 24 in alaska
it just so happens
that gun laws in alaska are not strict
and gun laws in new york and
massachusetts
are strict and once again we see that
correlation this one story is just an
anecdote but i think it's always
important to kind of pull out and to say
well what's the context in alaska and
what's the context in some of these
other states um for all of the you know
there's the the woke bashing that takes
place oh
new york is so dangerous and it's just
riddled with
urban gun crime euphemisms right
um
the gun homicide rate in alaska
is extraordinarily high
and anchorage alaska is consistently
for uh among in the united states a very
dangerous metro area when it comes to
violent crime barely ever makes the news
i don't know if it doesn't fit with the
narrative of the right i don't know if
it's because alaska is so geographically
distant from the contiguous 48 states i
don't pretend to know exactly why
but that is the truth those are the
numbers and just another horrible
horrible tragedy
and if only we could do something about
this right
oh wait this is a problem that plagues
the united states and almost no other
wealthy western nation yeah
make sure you follow us on facebook for
more on this and other stories from
today's show facebook.com slash david
pakman show
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
one of my favorite media stories that's
going on right now is that the more
extreme than fox news right-wing media
they smell blood in the water
they are starting to sense fox news may
be bailing on donald trump now they
haven't bailed on trump to be very clear
fox news is still sucking up to trump
and i'm going to give you some examples
in a moment but one of the things that
is happening in the lead up not not to
the 2022 midterms but to the 2024
republican primary is fox news wants an
off-ramp fox news wants to credibly be
able to get behind someone other than
donald trump if that is how the wins
turn and that person seems to be ron
desantis but fox isn't abandoning trump
right now they're just starting to play
up alternatives to trump including ron
desantis but
the other media outlets that want to
dethrone fox news as the
primary or most important right-wing
media outlet they smell blood in the
water and they're going after fox news
here is greg kelly on newsmax
accusing fox news of trying to cancel
donald trump
this is good for the left there's very
little that's good for the left right
now but right wing media going after
each other
i'll take whatever we can get
tone it down a notch uh mr vice
president nice guy
i like lots of things about him but not
everything and not january 6 and not
this i think he's kind of faking it just
a little bit all right so they banged
the gong fox news alert for mike pence
donald trump spoke at 3 p.m
what happened then
it's a very important issue and a lot of
republicans believe that uh they don't
like the covet voting rules that were in
place and they were so while donald
trump was speaking
at a major event in washington d.c the
first time he went back to washington
since he left the presidency they had a
bunch of people
doing this how dare they not cover
trump's big speech uh no donald trump
again it's between the billionaires it's
personal okay there's something personal
and uh
i don't like it i don't think it's uh
fair to donald trump they're trying to
cancel him actually you know i knew the
left wing was trying to cancel him but
the
conservative media as well
check this out newsmax had the whole
thing
if i renounce my beliefs
if i agreed to stay silent imagine
bragging that you broadcast this
if i stayed at home
and just took it easy
the persecution of donald trump would
stop immediately would stop
but that's not what i will do i can't do
that
all right he spoke for about an hour and
40 minutes it was fascinating it was all
good stuff we carried it live right here
on newsmax
but again fox news didn't they're trying
to cancel him conservative media tried
to cancel
the former president what now it is not
actually true that fox news has turned
on trump newsmax benefits from that
narrative understand that newsmax has a
vested interest in convincing viewers
that fox has turned on trump because
newsmax and fox share a lot of viewers
and if they are trumpist viewers and
they start to believe fox is now
anti-trump the only place to get my
pro-trump uh pablum is on newsmax it's
only good for newsmax's ratings now it's
not even really true okay fox news is
setting up an off-ramp that's all
they're doing but trump is furious about
it anyway the other day fox and friends
we played this clip they simply
mentioned poll numbers and trump lost it
you've got people from all across the
country convening in tampa i am thinking
about um
that is a little different than a couple
of other polls that we've seen over the
last couple of weeks two weeks ago in
florida blue point uh rather blueprint
polling did a poll uh desantis leads the
former president in all age groupings
then there was a university of new
hampshire poll in june
desantis actually led trump 39-37
and that uh new york times siena
a college poll that we decided quite a
few times less than half of republican
voters back donald trump as their
preferred choice so it's like the young
people
who are activists at that event right
like the former president but looking at
these other polls a different answer
yeah if you look state by state ron
desantis is showing tremendous strength
in new hampshire michigan and florida
he's leading or tied with the former
president
and turning point run by charlie kirk
extremely impressive organization and
they are extremely enthusiastic and
active us
okay
so they just read poll numbers that's
all they did and trump flipped out trump
trump immediately went on truth social
and said fox and friends just really
botched my poll numbers no doubt on
purpose that show has been terrible
going to the dark side they quickly vote
the big turning point poll they quickly
quote the big turning point poll victory
of almost 60 points over the number two
republican and then hammer me with
outliers actually almost all polls have
me reading leading all republicans and
biden by a lot
rhino paul ryan one of the weakest and
worst speakers ever must be running the
plays anyway thank you to turning point
the crowd and love was amazing that's it
was so mild so mild and if you want
proof that they're not really turning on
trump
just look at this from the same episode
yeah donald trump is playing in the
pro-am today with bryce and d chambeau
and i believe no not this there
everybody's wearing almost the exact
same clothes but it's actually not the
same episode i apologize playing in the
pro-am today with bryce and d chambeau
and i believe dustin johnson i i don't
know who's going to close out that he's
a scratch golfer um he is right i
believe they're all good golfers i think
you know the other one i know he's the
greatest golfing president ever really
athletic that's right yeah very very
much a good golfer sucking up to him and
then uh here's another one where now fox
and friends is on the defensive
they talk about poll numbers
but then they remember
to say we didn't invent the numbers 55
percent of republicans or people leaning
republican
wants somebody other than donald trump
to run that's up six percent from their
earlier poll and if the foreign
president's watching you should know
those are the just the numbers you're
relaying you didn't come up with those
numbers right cnn came up with it right
ainsley said if this was a fascinating
poll it is that's why we just talked
about it now i had to do the same thing
remember last week i told you guys that
joe biden's approval rating is in the
toilet
and people were furious at me for
reporting those numbers i actually
hilariously had to do the same
disclaimer where i was like guys i
didn't do the polling it's not
reflective of my opinion and they are
right as often as haley's comet comes by
every seven years so you're just saying
all we talked about for the last four
minutes is not accurate i'm just saying
donald trump trump is watching and to
see it if donald trump is watching just
let him know we didn't come up with that
number that's what the poll said
right absolutely
they're treating him like a little kid
it's it's it's amazing actually he was
talking to uh yeah yeah
i was talking to a pollster about these
numbers and they seem to be across the
board regarding some few people in the
democratic party one child it's just too
soon to tell there's so many different
polls and they all say different
the majority of the democratic they are
stumbling all over themselves to avoid
angering donald trump so listen fox news
hasn't fully turned on trump fox news is
setting up an off-ramp that's what
they're doing and newsmax is trying to
take advantage of it this is the power
struggle happening right now within
right-wing media
i care about it to the extent that maybe
it's bad for republicans that would be
great
let's talk about an incredible
uh
ah what is it it's sort of like a set
like a like a circular firing squad
that's taking place
republicans
are increasingly worried
that maybe they're not going to do so
well in november of 2022 why well
because the polling says they might not
do so well
and so
people like marjory taylor-greene
are now saying
i don't know that that many republicans
are going to vote
which may be true
and then she immediately repeats the big
lie that the 2020 election was stolen
which would only encourage republicans
not to vote well what do i mean by that
if you believe your vote doesn't matter
because it's going to be stolen or eaten
or flushed or whatever
then you are less likely to go out and
vote if i knew my vote wouldn't count
why am i going to take time to go out
and vote so even though they're worried
about low turnout republicans are
lowering turnout by insisting on the big
lie here's a clip from marjorie taylor
greene on graham allen's dear america
podcast i'm not familiar with the show
but she she appeared on it
um
it's like a cognitive dissonance almost
i'm a little more cautious so am i i
don't think it's gonna be a big red wave
um but but maybe it will be but i'll
tell you the biggest problem i'm
concerned about is i'm concerned about
the people that are still angry and
don't want to vote right and we need
them to vote because
no matter i mean i i mean i was i'm one
of the
first people that'll tell you i don't
believe uh the election results of 2020
have no problem absolutely not i believe
trump won i i objected proudly on
january 6 and i would do it again today
and tomorrow if i could um but but i
think there's people that feel that way
and they're still angry and they may not
want to vote but we have to if we don't
vote we are handing over victory to the
radical godless left and so to me that's
one of my concerns is i'm worried people
won't vote yeah listen guys i'm very
worried people won't vote because they
were angry that the election was stolen
and their votes didn't count and it was
stolen and their votes didn't count and
i'm furious furious furious about that
but we need people to vote well but why
would they vote if their votes going to
be stolen and not counted or whatever
this strategy
probably lost them the senate if you go
back and think about the 2020 election
there were the two special elections in
georgia there were it would these are
the seats ultimately won by raphael
warnock and john ossoff it was january
5th of 2021
they spent the period between november
of 2020 and january 5 2021
insisting that their votes didn't count
that the entire thing is rigged that
they're going to steal it again
and that depressed turnout and
ultimately they did lose and some of
those races were not i don't remember
the exact number let me see if i can
even find them january 5 2021 special
georgia election results
let's see what those were
um ultimately assaf won
won by 1.2 percentage points and warnock
won by two okay it is completely
plausible that insisting that it was all
stolen and it's all rigged for two
months plus
two months basically between the
november election and the january
special elections that they lost control
of the senate because of that it could
be 52 to 48 republicans were it not for
this very strategy and now marjorie
taylor green just repeats it she is
encouraging people not to vote by saying
it was stolen the votes didn't count on
and on and on
i don't believe in overt voter
suppression as a tactic to win elections
so you will never hear me say on this
show
stuff to try to trick republicans into
not voting i know that there are people
who say well
uh the the the ends justify the means
and there are some on the left who say
it would be fine to try to trick
republicans into thinking election day
is a different day than it is or
whatever
that's
that's beneath me i can't do that that
that seems immoral to me
but i'm certainly not going to tell
republicans not to do it themselves and
if they want to continue insisting
insisting insisting
that it was stolen votes don't count it
could happen again it's all going to be
fraud
uh then by all means let them go ahead
and do that and see what the uh what
what the actual turnout is um we have a
voicemail number that
number is two 219 to david p
here's a really good question
that came in
about the obsession from many on the
right with trans people take a listen to
this
hi david um as for why
people are so obsessed with trans people
i myself am not trans but many of my
best friends are
it's actually
really based in white supremacy
in that being a straight white man
is their entire identity and if the
gender binary
it doesn't exist the way they think that
it does then
their entire is an entire existential
crisis that they can't deal with because
their entire identity is based on being
a straight white man
so it's a lot more complicated than that
and the gender binary is very
complicated across multiple cultures but
that's my two cents so there's a couple
different things going on first of all i
i think
some people don't like it when i say
this
i really could not care less about
gender and sexuality in the sense of it
impacting my uh opinion or conversations
that i want to have with people and what
i mean by that is
i
i'm not being pejorative when i say this
i'm really bored by all of this stuff of
what identity and who's what and who do
you date and who are you attracted to
and what's your gender
i have so many things that i tend to
find of interest to talk about with
people regardless of their identity
that i find all of this stuff really
really boring i treat everybody with
respect
i don't care how you want to identify
i don't care who you're attracted to i
just it's just not interesting to me i
consider all of these just people's
personal choices and i'm fine with
whatever as long as you're not hurting
people committing crimes the things i'm
concerned with are people who regardless
of their identity are just not good
people that those are my concerns okay
so for me it's like i just i just don't
care do whatever you want see whoever
okay now that doesn't mean i ignore the
fact
that there are people targeted and
treated terribly because of their
identity now why is it such a point of
obsession for so many on the right right
now it's trans people um it's it's in a
sense there's two things going on one
it is much more
what's the word i'm going to say it's
can it's now much more accepted to be
gay and lesbian by the way lesbianism
has for a long time been the most
accepted that's the least offensive
that's for a long time if you sort of
like rank the things that the homophobic
transphobic etc right wingers are angry
about
lesbians is usually the thing that
they're least angry about then you've
got gay people and when it comes to gay
men
they have to a great degree kind of said
okay gay marriage is legal uh you can't
fire people for their real or perceived
sexual orientation anymore we got to
kind of ease up on that and also i think
that the public opinion has shifted and
more and more people even right wingers
are generally
uh
tolerant if not absolutely fine with gay
people as a general thing although
homophobia still exists so now you've
got trans
and within trans
you have a number of different aspects
that people can choose to become enraged
about there's the trans adoption part
there is the characterizing trans people
as predators this is the bathroom stuff
remember that was when bathrooms were
the big flash point it was all about
well
biological men
will
lie that they are actually uh wanting to
exist in the world as women simply to go
hang out in women's bathrooms and girls
locker rooms and it's like of course
that's not happening and also
uh acting like a predator
would get you in trouble no matter what
you have as gender identity it just it
didn't make any sense but that was one
aspect that they could
they've been pushing the gay men or
pedophiles thing for a long time
wrongly so
but it seemed like they had a really
specific way to do it with trans people
that was less overtly transphobic to
some and so they could get away with it
i think that that's one component of it
number two
it's entered the political milieu for
the right because of transports and
donald trump openly you know doing his
weightlifting mimicry and the entire
thing about transports so that's another
aspect that is entered in if you have a
competition
uh
among men and some of the men are gay it
doesn't give you the same opportunity to
claim things are unfair
that the narrative about uh trans
athletes has given so that's sort of
like another aspect to it um and then
beyond that they they seem obsessed to
some degree
uh because the focus has been on
cultural issues more specifically lately
and so they don't really have policy to
talk about i think it's sort of like a
little bit of all of the above that's
why the right has become so obsessed
with uh with trans people if there's
elements of it that i'm missing let me
know we have a great bonus show for you
today
andrew yang's forward party the third
party has now formally launched we will
talk about it what is their policy we
don't know yet but they're going to
announce it very very soon
secondly the biden administration is
offering to return to russia a convicted
arms dealer to get brittany griner back
that's the female basketball player
who's been imprisoned in russia for a
period of time now there is now a
negotiation happening we will talk about
it and number three two former police
officers have now been sentenced for
violating george floyd's civil rights
this is going above and beyond um the
initial trial and we will talk about
that as well all of those stories and
more are available on today's bonus show
to get the bonus show you've got to be a
member that's the only requirement you
sign up at joinpackman.com
you will instantly have access to the
bonus show and of course if you would
like a discount off of membership use
the coupon code big voting
22 we will see you then or on the friday